OK, everyone.
Good morning.
This is Jack Van Horn from the University
of Southern California and the BD2K Training
Coordinating Center, and I'd like to welcome
you all to our next installment of The Big
Data to Knowledge, BD2K, Guide to the Fundamentals
of Data Science.
This is our section three on computing and
computing technologies.
And I am very, very pleased to introduce Umit
Catalyurek who's Professor and Associate Chair
at the Georgia Institute of Technology.
He is a professor in the School of Computational
Science and Engineering there at Georgia Tech.
He received his PhD in 2000 from Bilkent University,
and he is the recipient of a NSF Career Award,
a number of other grants, and a primary investigator
on several key awards from the Department
of Energy, the National Institute of Health,
and the National Science Foundation.
He serves as an associate editor for the journal
Parallel Computing, and is an editorial board
member for IEEE Transactions on Parallel and
Distributed Computing and the Journal of Parallel
and Distributed Computing.
He was the founding general chair of the first
ACM International Health Informatics Symposium
in 2010.
He served as program chair for several other
ACM and IEEE related activities.
His main research interests are in parallel
computing, combinatorial scientific computing,
and biomedical informatics.
His lecture today is going to be entitled
Modern Computing: Cloud, Distributed and High
Performance.
And this is going to be a lecture with a sort
of a crash course on computer architecture,
high performance computing, and parallel computation.
And he's going to be very briefly discussing
how to classify computer architectures, how
to help make your code parallelizable without
too much technical details, I understand.
But how you may do this and achieve the best
performance on different architectures.
And before we begin, let me remind you that
you can text in your questions using the questions
submission system here on our GoToWebinar.
And please do that, and then at the end, I
will ask those questions of Umit at the end
on your behalf.
Without further ado, Umit, thank you so much.
We're very much looking forward to your presentation.
Thank you very much, Jack, for this humbling
introduction.
As Jack mentioned, right now I'm at Georgia
Institute of Technology, but I was at Ohio
State for 15 years at the Department of Biomedical
Informatics.
I was one of the founding faculty members
who started the department, and just before
I moved here I was one of the co-directors
of MIDAs multi-modeling and Integrative Data
Analytics Training Program.
So I am always motivated by biomedical applications.
I'm a computer scientist at heart, so this
talk will be, as Jack mentioned, from the
more computational perspective.
And I will try to give you a brief introduction,
a quick little crash course on computer architecture
in general high performance computing architectures.
I need to provide some background information
so that we are all on the same page.
Then, I will focus on three, I will say, golden
rules that when you're making your application
faster on high performance computing or today's
computing environment.
And I will give some simple examples there,
and I will finish up with one application
that shows many of those techniques to get
a [? combine ?]
So let's start with high performance computing.
What do we really mean by high performance
computing?
It's one of those terms that there's really
no agreed upon terminology.
One can say that there's no such thing as
low performance computing, so all of the computing
has to be high performance.
Why one would want to compute anything slow,
you want to compute everything fast, which
I couldn't agree more.
Couple definitions from a couple of different
places, I don't want to read all of these,
but what I want to point out that many of
those definitions really tells that aggregating
computing power to solve bigger problem.
And it talks about a need for high bandwidth
[? NIS ?] network and high computing capabilities.
But the definition I would like to use is
something a little bit simpler.
I just want to use available computing platforms
to run my applications quickly, and I want
to do this very efficiently.
So for me, that's what high performance computing
is.
It doesn't always mean supercomputing, but
I'll come to that in a minute.
So why do we care about speed?
Well, clearly, there are many reasons and
there is no point in laboring the point.
We don't want science to wait for computing,
we want to compute fast so that we can make
the scientific advancement faster.
But what I would like to emphasize is we really
need to care about efficiency in computing.
So when we make computation efficient-- that
means if we can leverage the computational
resources much better --that means there will
be more resources available to all of us.
So you can do more computations so efficiency
is important.
One thing that's sometimes overlooked is also,
someone has to pay the bills.
So if you're doing a computation say in a
cloud computing environment, if you only care
about getting it fast and if you're using
thousands of processors, are you going to
pay for thousands of processors?
But if you can do it efficiently on less number
of processors, that will be also very fast
as well.
So I can prove that, but I don't really have
time to do that, so I just want to emphasize
that whenever you are looking for application,
as much as you want it to run it fast, you
really want to be efficient as well.
So supercomputing is definitely HPC.
But in my definition, HPC doesn't just mean
supercomputing.
We will look at some supercomputers.
Not all of us will have access to those kind
of supercomputers, but I want to tell you
a few
things about high performance computing and
architecture so that you can use in whatever
the environments you have.
So let me start with computing today.
So I'm going to argue that computing today
really means parallel computing, and you need
to do high performance computing.
Why is that?
Well, first of all, any computer you touch
today has parallel processing power.
And I will start with a very simple example,
your laptop probably has at least two cores.
Inside the CPU, it has two cores that can
do two things at the same time.
And even your cell phone will have 4 to 8
cores today.
So that means that any computer you see will
have multiple processing power elements.
So it's there so we have to use them.
The second rationale is well, this is BD2K
7, we're talking about big data and science
and hence the computational data need is really
big.
We really need to solve some problems that
today, you cannot fit into whatever your local
computer, your desktop computer, is.
So some examples are clearly-- includes a
genomic applications for example, method genomics
is one case.
If you want to solve method genomics code
problem, you will not be able to run most
likely in your laptop.
You will need some machine that has much bigger
memory.
And the other thing is in some cases, you
may fit into your computer, but it may be
taking too long.
So we don't really have time to do this.
So that's why we need to take into account
parallelism, and we need to make it efficient.
So basically, three reasons.
One is well, it's there, all the computations,
resources today has parallelism, so if you're
not using them, you're wasting those resources.
The second is your problem doesn't fit in
your small computer so you have to do it parallel.
The third is it takes too long and you want
to do it fast.
And just to show that tsunami of data, these
are some slides that you probably have seen
a few times already.
So just sequences and whole genome sequencing
data in [? Janbang ?] is really exponentially
growing, and we have more than petabyte of
data.
And we are getting some technologies like
Oxford Nanopores, which are small and will
make even generational to data much faster.
So now I want to switch gears and go into
a little bit computer architecture.
So this is a chart of the performance of a
single processor over the time starting from
early 1978 to 2012 or so, but the trend is
very similar after this point.
What I want to highlight here is if you're
doing science between mid-'80s and 2003, if
you want to make your code faster, all you
had to do was just wait.
If you wait 18 months, you'll get a faster
processor almost twice as fast and your code
will run fast.
But around 2003, we actually hit a few technological
barriers that computer architects had to change
the way that we produce processors.
And this is where we start having multicore
processors.
From that point on, if you want to get your
code faster you cannot just rely on time and
simple technology advancements that will make
your existing sequential code run fast.
You really have to think about parallelism.
sequential code run fast.
One thing I really want to highlight here
when we talk about speed and we're measuring
the performance of the program, we usually
use two terms, bandwidth and latency, or throughput
or response time similarly means the same
thing.
The bandwidth is the total work done in a
given time.
So if you are, for example, doing sequence
mapping, you have input reads.
How many of those reads you can map in a second,
this is your bandwidth.
The latency is the time between start and
completion of the event.
So in that case, the latency of mapping a
single read is the time it takes really finding
that in the whole genome pointing in that
location.
As you can guess from these problem description,
increasing bandwidth or throughput is much
easier actually.
You control more resources and you can get
to higher bandwidth or higher throughput.
But reducing the latency, getting faster response
time is not that easy.
And you will see that in computer architecture
as well.
If you plot the relative latency improvement
over the bandwidth improvements-- against
the bandwidth improvement, you'll see that
all of the computer technology, including
processors, network disk, the bandwidth's
really improved much higher than latency.
What does it mean?
We're really adding more type of resources,
so you really need to take advantage of those
parallelism in your code to be able to make
it fast.
OK.
Now, I'm going to talk about, really, computer
architectures.
And I'm going to use Flynn's taxonomy on how
we classify the computer architectures.
So in one axis, we are looking at how many
instructions we can run at any point in time.
And we will just classify them as, I can run
a single instruction or I can run multiple
instruction with any point in time.
And in the other axis, we'll look at the data.
How many data element I can process at any
time?
It will be either single or multiple.
So on the upper left corner is single instruction,
single data corner, which is your sequential
computer.
So, basically, you can process one data at
any given time.
There are alternative architectures where
you can actually do process multiple data
elements, but operate and do the same instruction.
Let me just show them a picture of it.
So this is your single instruction, single
data.
Basically, your standard CPU.
So you have input data coming and your processor
is doing one instruction at a time and producing
the outputs.
That's your basic sequential code.
I'll turn it the way of you have to do a repetitive
task that you can actually do the same.
You will do the same processing in multiple
elements.
Instead of doing them one by one, you can
process them in chunks, in a box.
These are also called vector machines.
And today, actually, GPUs more or less falls
into this category.
So these are single instruction, multiple
data machines.
So what's the difference between these two
architectures?
On the left side we are showing a GPU and
on the right
is a CPU.
Current CPUs are designed for latency.
So they operate in-- well, single core of
CPU operates on single data elements.
And it's really designed to give fast response
to single problem.
On the other side, GPUs are really optimized
for throughput.
So where the difference comes from in the
chip design actually.
What makes chip more complicated is the control
flow.
If you want your chip to do different things,
the control flow becomes more complicated.
So GPUs takes advantage of that and have a
single control unit but multiple arithmetic
units that they can do the operation.
So with that they can produce a higher throughput
and they can actually be more energy efficient
with that as well.
So, but if you come to today's world where
we actually have architectures which have
multiple processors operating on different
data elements.
And they can be actually in different forms.
One of them is the shared memory view of the
architectures.
We used to call them SMPs-- symmetric multi-processors.
In that case, you have multiple processors.
They can all access to single memory, same
memory, but they can do independent work.
This will be your workstation with multi-cores
or the multiprocessors in it.
Then we can go one step further, which handles
have processors connected through it and network.
This will be gigabit network or much faster
networks like InfiniBand.
In that case, each person will have a local
direct access to its memory, but if they need
to do something together, they need to communicate
over network.
And, of course, we can have the hybrid model
that there are multiple processors.
Or today's, actually, we have the really--
sorry for the typo.
Heterogeneous.
Computers which have different types of processing
units and each computing node and they are
connected through a network.
So let me just very quickly go over supercomputer.
So this is an HPC lecture, so I need to talk
about supercomputers.
So I'm going to start with a code attributes,
Seymour Cray of the Cray computers.
If you were plowing a field, which would you
rather use?
Two strong oxens or 1,024 chickens?
So, as you can see, this comes from a computer
scientist.
It doesn't say 1,000.
It says 1,024 chickens.
And the answer to this question is not that
easy, actually.
It really depends what you want to do.
If you don't need to plow really deep and
if you have a good mechanism to control those
chickens, you can actually plow larger field
with 1,024 chickens, right?
But if you need to plow deep, you really need
to use two strong oxens.
And today's supercomputers are composed of
different architectures that are a mixture
of these two dilemmas.
So on one side you have very powerful processing
elements.
They are connected to each other with fast
networks.
On the other side, you have computing elements
that are not that powerful by themselves,
like a single computing
element in the GPU may be, but as they're
combined together, they are much more powerful.
Top 500 is a website that lists world's fastest
supercomputers that are known to us.
At MIT, of course, other computers that we
are not aware of.
These are basically ranked by some application,
some linear algebra solution to some linear
algebra problem.
So people argue that this is not a good representation
of the old application portfolio.
But, nevertheless, this is one of the lists.
And what I want to show here is just look
at the number of cores column here.
Today we're talking about 10 million cores.
So if you want to really get high performance
on such a supercomputer, really need to think
about massively parallelizing your computation.
At the bottom, you can see a chart that's
plotted from the beginning of the Top 500
list is about 1993, today.
And one shows the number one in this list.
As you can see, we are reaching about 100
petaflops and the goal to reach the exa scale,
exaflops, initial goal was 2018.
Now we're pushing about 2021.
And we're making progress in that.
What I want you to look at-- take, for example,
one of the horizontal lines here.
Let's say 10 teraflops.
The number one machine was about in 2001,
2002, was 10 teraflops.
And in 2008, the bottom of the list, just
six years after, had that power.
So about six to eight years number one machine
becomes number 500.
And if you actually add another six to 10
years and six to eight, six to 10 years, that
number 500 machine power, you'll have it in
your desktop.
So between about 14, 15 years, you may have
a computer that was as fast as world's fastest
computer 15 years ago.
Another thing that I want to highlight is
your number one is really clearly separated
from the rest.
If you look at the sum of power, the difference
between number one and sum and number one
and number 500.
Number one is closer to the sum.
So, really, this is a top-heavy list.
So very quickly-- I don't want to go too much
detail-- this is the progress of type of the
architectures we have.
Initially there were signal processors that
were fastest machines.
But if you just look at this decade, you'll
see that it's basically two types of computers.
Basically, one is clusters that are built
on commodity hardware, similar to the way
most of your workstations.
They are just connected with some little bit
faster networking flilibands and variants.
Or there are some, about 20%, really, designed
as supercomputers like IBM Blue Gene or the
number one machine in our current architecture.
Chip technology is also-- we will see that
commodity hardwares are becoming more prevalent.
What I want to highlight here is, as I said
earlier, since 2003 we are using mostly multi-core
architectures.
But starting from 2010, so beginning of this
decade, you will see what I call attack of
many cores.
Those are GPUs, [INAUDIBLE], or those kind
of accelerators that I have, really those
1024 [INAUDIBLE] type of processors, the [? SAMD
?] processors,
which, by themselves, they are not, individually
they're not powerful, but combined together
that they become much more powerful.
And as you can see, almost one fifth of the
Top500 machines have those architectures.
So, now, I want to change the topic.
So I gave you a brief overview of what the
processors look like, how they're really composed,
and what the current supercomputers look like.
And now I want to look at from the application
perspective.
So let's say that you have an application.
And you want to speed up that application.
When I talk about application, I will use
the term workflow interchangeably.
So there was another talk two weeks ago.
[? Igor Romy ?] actually explained workflows
wonderfully.
So there's the workflows were at the higher
level [? now, ?] but here what I'm talking
about will, workflow is an application itself.
So we'll look at parts of the workflow and
we'll try to figure out how we can make your
application, your workflow, faster.
The first thing that I will say, and those
three rules actually, they are really, if
you look at the more common sense rules, but
we tend to overlook them, so I want to emphasize
a little bit.
So I have some questions [? on ?] the slide,
but just ignore the equations [INAUDIBLE]
for timing, just look at the bottom.
So let's say that one on the left, the bars,
blue and green bars, shows my application.
Let's say that I notice that on the green
part is something that's I'm doing repetitively
and I can do much faster, or it's running
on one processor that I can actually get a
faster processor for that.
And let's say I'm improving that and I'm getting
what's viewed on the right hand side.
So the question is, what's the speed up I
can get?
So you can play with the arithmetic at the
top, and you'll see that new execution time
is, of course, the blue parts, which I haven't
improved.
They will stay.
And I'm just improving the green part.
And what I would [INAUDIBLE] to the improvement
is that that will actually be limiting factor
for my speedup.
Actually, another way of saying this, let's
say that I have infinite resources and I improve
that green part so that it's practically zero.
Then the maximum speed up is 1 divided by
1 minus the fraction that I improved, which
is that [? parenthesis ?] says, whatever left
is in the blue.
So what does it mean?
Let's say that you have a sequence analysis
pipeline, and you have one slow step.
So you call it slow.
And it does error correction, for example,
of the input reads.
So you want to do it fast.
And someone says that, hey, there's a CPU
that's 10 times faster to do those kind of
things.
And that sounds very appealing.
You want to definitely use it.
But when you look at the application, you
realize that applications actually I/O bound,
meaning that it's reading
and writing the file 60% of time, only 40%
of time is really doing that computation.
So if you just plug the numbers here, what
you will see that your speed up will be it
was 1.56.
So we were talking about a CPU that's 10 times
faster, right?
We are really attracted to those numbers because
they are big, but we lost the perspective
that this will actually only give us 1.6 time
speed up.
So another application that we have done in
my group, a long time ago actually, is multiple
sequence alignments.
So this is a combinatorial problem, finding
the optimal solution, optimum in the sense
of computational, not biological, because
in the computers, we have to have a function
to define optimality.
And using that, if we actually use an optimal
algorithm, which will basically enumerate
all possible solutions, even if it's a small
number of sequences, this may take hours.
And if you add a few more sequences, this
may take years, right?
Some of the problems will be intractable,
so we cannot solve them optimally, but we
have good algorithms, heuristic algorithms
which will solve them in a faster time.
And Clustal W was one of them.
So I'm not going to go into details of the
algorithm, but what I want to say is algorithm
may basically have three phases, pairwise
alignment, guide tree computation, and progressive
alignment.
And when we actually look at the execution
time of the algorithm, if you look at that
chart on the top left, we notice that pairwise
alignment was really taking quite a bit of
time, depending on how many sequences you
have.
And by [? increasing ?] the sequences, the
guide tree also becoming, taking too much
time.
But for most of our application case it was
about 400, so it was taking more than 90%
of the time.
So we thought, it's great.
We met that [? part ?] parallel.
And as we did.
So if you look at the chart on the right bottom,
so the green line shows the ideal speed up
you can get with preprocessors, if you have
drawing preprocessors, what you expect if
your computation get p times faster.
And as you can see, a pairwise alignment phase
of the algorithm, actually, with [INAUDIBLE]
linear speed up.
That's fantastic.
But again, going back to Amdahl's law, plugging
this into the question and looking at, in
total, what was our speed up, you will see
that the speed up was just three, using 8
processors.
So just again, to highlight, emphasize this
a little bit more, so this is just plot of
if 10% of your code is sequential, that you
cannot parallelize what's the maximum speed
up you can get?
And on the x-axis I have from zero to 8,000
processors.
And you don't see that line because underneath
of all of them, and as you can see, it's really
actually less than 10.
If you look at the best line I plotted to
here, it says if you have 1/10 of 1%, so 1,000
of your program was sequential, so it can't
parallelize that part, but you parallelize
all of the rest, that's the speed up you will
get.
As you can see, you get pretty decent speed
up, up to 1,000 or so.
But after that it starts letting out.
And even if [? it ?] [? through ?] 8,000 processors,
you only get 900 speedup, right?
So you're practically wasting 7,000 processors
at this point.
So this is one thing you really need to pay
attention when you want to make your code
faster.
So, and I don't think that I would say that
you need to pay attention, is pay attention
to locality.
So like many years, our computers are composed
of memory hierarchies, such that no one in
the hierarchy has a larger space, but their
speed is slower.
So from CPU, to cache, to memory, to disk,
as you go down, you will get a larger and
larger space, but access time becomes really
much slower and slower.
So what this tells us, really, if you can
structure your computation such that it actually
fits into memory at the upper levels, you
will actually speed up your computation really,
really fast.
So you really need to pay attention to this,
and at least think about how we can reorder
the computation, such that you can keep the
data most of the time in memory, or most of
the time in cache, if you can actually do
that.
And another point in the pay attention to
locality is in some applications, this was
basically a visualization application we have
done, again quite a bit of time ago, you may
have the data actually in distributed settings.
So you may have, your [? collaborator ?] may
have been, for example, generating some data.
In this particular case, we were looking at
different acquisition models for image modalities.
And you want to create a visualization that
integrates all of this data.
The data sits in a remote location.
You have some computing power, which you can
do the rendering.
But your work station is not connected to
any of those.
So obviously, the one thing you can do, you
can transfer all of the data to a visualization
center.
But that may require quite a bit of time depending
on the network they have in between.
So instead, what you should be doing is you
really need to look at what user wants to
visualize, extract that data from the storage,
pass that to your rendering servers.
Once they actually render, then you can get
to the client.
So basically, the point here is instead of
moving the data to computation, you should
really move the computation to data.
In this case, simple indexing, filtering,
and creating the appropriate data structure.
Move to where data [? originally ?] stored.
Then we only move the data that we'll require
for our rendering.
And then from there, we only move to the client
just a single image to display on the computer.
So that's the second thing you need to really
pay attention to look out in.
And the third and the most difficult one is
maybe is the take of advantage of parallelism.
So I have different types of applications
here.
And I have one biological application, well,
three classes that I will describe.
I will broadly categorize the applications
into three classes.
One of them is what I call bag-of-tasks model.
So in that case, you have some computation
that you need to do that's they are independent
of each other, but they may depend on some
input files.
And DCMRI was one of the applications we actually
used, developed.
And that fits into this model.
So you have the tasks.
And they are dependent on some files.
And you can just independently parallelize
those to get efficiency.
The second set of applications, which I'll
call non-streaming workflows in general--
so, for example, [? general ?] mapping and
alignment is one of them.
In that case, you have a workflow.
So it could be simple pipeline, or it could
be a [INAUDIBLE] cyclic graph.
Part of it maybe you can do parallel, but
you need to do first task.
Then you can do the second, and third task
in the second level, and so on and so forth.
And the third class of the application is
you still have a workflow, but you have multiple
data elements that you can go through that
workflow.
I'll call them streaming applications.
OK?
And each of these applications categories
gives you a different parallelism.
For example, in bag-of-tasks model, so you
can take these tasks and give each of these
tasks to different processors.
OK?
So obviously, if you have more tasks than
processors, you can do multiple tasks to one
processor.
In that case, you again need to pay attention
to the locality.
If you have multiple tasks that using the
same set of input files, then you put them
in the same processor.
And you want to make sure that the total execution
time is minimized by giving same amount of
work to everyone else.
So I'll call this as a task parallelism.
OK?
The second one is non-streaming workflow.
So in that case, let's say that we finished
the first phase and first task there, and
we're doing the second.
We are in the second level.
We can actually do those two tasks parallel
to each other.
And we can also maybe take advantage of one
more level of parallelism, data parallelism
to do one of the heavy tasks that can be parallelized.
So we distribute that into multiple processors.
We do the data parallelism.
And we can do the task parallelism by running
two different tasks concurrently on the pilot
machine.
OK?
And the last one is streaming workflow, which
basically give us one more parallelism.
Once you finish the very first task, processing
of the very first elemental by way of first
task, then you are ready to process them in
the second level.
And you can do that concurrently with new
data elements, starting from the first task.
So you can basically pipeline the execution.
That way you can actually really reduce to
execution time nicely.
You can still use data parallelism.
You can still use task parallelism.
So the important thing for you to look at
is your application and figure out which of
these types of parallelism is available for
your application.
OK?
So I'm going to use whole-slide to put those
image analysis for neuroblastoma.
This is an application that we
developed with multiple collaborators, including
Dr. [? Shimada ?] from Los Angeles and my
old friend, good old friend, Dr. [? Mettinger,
?] who developed image analysis algorithms.
The process basically mimics what a pathologist
is doing when they are [? reviewing ?] the
whole-slides.
So it starts with the lower resolution of
the image.
And if a simple diagnosis can be done at that
level, it's done.
If not, then you will go into select some
regions.
And you'll go into higher-level resolutions
and try to make the diagnosis based on the
image which [? are ?] there.
And the workflow for this is given at the
bottom, so you have multiple steps starting
from color conversion to some physical features,
looking at histograms and classifications.
And if you cannot classify, you go back and
go one level higher resolution.
So just it's a busy slide.
But the point of this slide is, why do we
need to use HPC?
We're talking about these size pathology slides.
These can be 120,000 by 120,000 pixels, [? 40
?] gigabytes of memory.
And most of the time, our collaborators work
their algorithms in MATLAB.
And if you just look at one small tile of
this image, like 1,000 by 1,000 pixels, it
will takes about 6 seconds in MATLAB.
If you convert that into more efficient programming
with C, you can get to less than a second.
But even with that, even for a small slide
and half of the background, it will take about
20 minutes to actually analyze the slide.
So what we really want to do to make this
practical, useful in the clinical setting,
we needed to get this under couple of seconds,
because you may really need to look at multiple
slides per patient.
And basically, processing this, which just
current CP algorithms will not scale.
You will need more than a year to process
one year worth of data.
So how do we do that?
So first of all, we can chop the big image,
the slide, into small tiles.
When I say small, maybe 1,000 by 1,000 or
4,000 by 4,000 pixels.
On the left side is one slide.
And each of those small boxes is one tile.
Then we can give those tiles to computational
units.
We can have multiple computational units,
CPUs, GPUs, and [INAUDIBLE] files.
And we want to process them through them and
get the classification out of it.
So this application actually provides all
of those three levels of parallelism I mentioned.
So first of all, if you look at the workflow,
there were different steps.
So there were different tasks.
So I can do them concurrently, and I can pipeline
them as well.
What I can also do, I can take advantage of
data parallelism.
Here, more deeply, this is an application
that some of the things that I'm computing
fits very well to GPU's scheme of computing,
basically single instruction, multiple data.
So what I'm showing here is, again, too much
information this slide.
But just if you look at the top row, there
are different tasks in my workflow.
And we list how many-- what size of input
and output is producing.
Is it
computationally heavy or not?
Is there locality?
Is it accessing the same data or not?
And all of them have different characteristics.
And we have implemented the GPU version of
all of those phases, and what we have seen,
really, each one of them gives different speedup,
right?
The speed up, with respect to a single CPU
core, which I will tell that that's usually
not a good way of representing numbers.
But just to be able to compare those for having
a single baseline is good.
Speedup can be from 166 to eight times.
So since your CPU also have multiple cores,
you can actually do multiple of them.
So if you have a CPU with eight cores, really,
doing the histogram computation in GPU doesn't
make sense, because it's not really giving
you a faster execution time.
Yet another [? basic ?] slide.
Title recalculation rate means the times that
we call the higher resolution.
So as that increases, we need to process bigger
and bigger tiles.
If you just look at the bottom top-left chart
and the bottom white bars, that's how much
time it takes-- how much speedup I get with
using GPU only processing.
On top of it, I have some workflow optimizations
which includes how to efficiently use pipelining
and overlapping computations and communications,
which we don't need to go into detail.
As the tile gets bigger, doing it in GPU obviously
gets bigger, because you have more data elements
to process to do the same computation.
So this fits to GPU very well.
But what I want to highlight at the bottom,
if you look at the chart on the right, this
is actually the same thing.
But what we are adding is additional CPU processors.
They don't have GPU.
So we have a heterogeneous environment.
So we are just adding CPUs.
So we are adding same number of CPUs.
So that means one may expect to get two times
speedup.
We actually get three times speedup.
So how is that possible?
It's possible because we were not efficiently
utilizing GPUs.
Some of the computations like processing the
small tiles, they are really not good for
doing those kind of computations in GPU.
To get the best out of GPU, you really need
to process a larger amount of data, and you
should be doing the same type of work.
So I guess I've run really, really fast.
So that wasn't really my intention, but I
think I may have more time for more questions,
I guess.
So I talked about really high-performance
computing until now, and my title says distributed
computing, cloud computing.
What about cloud computing?
So let me just take a few minutes of time
and talk about cloud computing.
So even though names has clouds-- I guess
everyone in this talk knows that it's not
really in the cloud.
It's someone else's computer, right?
So it's nice that there are many companies
and agencies that are providing us these as
resources.
And in many cases, these are offered in case
of Amazon cloud and Microsoft cases.
These are offered by companies, and they are
models for-- you rent your computing power
instead of buying that computing power.
Which is great, if you don't need the computation
24/7 in your lab, and you have times that
you actually need to analyze the data.
And you need to just-- during that time, if
you can have access, that's great.
And in that case, cloud computing is really
helpful.
But one thing you really need to pay attention,
you really need to pay for computer data storage
and transfer, right?
So all of these actually comes back to my
golden rules that I told you.
You're paying for the compute time.
So you need to make sure that you're efficiently
using computational time, so that you're not
wasting your computational time.
You're going to pay for data storage, and
of course, [INAUDIBLE] data, but you'll be
also paying for the data transfer.
So minimizing the data transfer will help
you to save money as well.
So I don't want to sound negative about it.
In contrast, I'm extremely happy that we have
this infrastructure.
This is actually probably our best bet right
now to get sharing of the large data workflows
and computational resources between multiple
institutions.
So after many different iterations of earlier
distribute computing, grid computing standardization
efforts, this is actually really one way that
we can finally get to share large data and
workflows and work together.
And also, for most of us, not everyone has
direct access to the supercomputers.
This is really our best bet to get scalability
and speed.
So because I don't really have time, I cannot
go into detail how you can really use this.
But everything we're discussing really applies
to cloud computing as well.
If you look at, for example, Amazon today,
they offer multiple virtual machines and instances
with different number of cores.
They even offer it with the GPUs.
And Microsoft has also has started offering
the instances with the GPUs as well.
I will just point to one of the review papers
that I used to give as a reading assignment
to my students from the Nature [INAUDIBLE]
Genetics, even though I don't really agree
for everything that's said there.
To me, heterogeneous computing is not really
much different than cloud computing, because
it's really converged to the same thing.
Now, cloud computing has given the heterogeneous
compute platforms for us.
It's a good review to looking at different
applications and how they may also map to
some of those resources.
What's more entertaining for me was to also
read the correspondences following this, too,
this paper by groups [INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
the author's response.
And they're arguing the suitability of the
cloud from different perspectives, which was
interesting, because both of them were correct
in their arguments, but they were not really
arguing the same thing.
One was talking about transferring one petabyte
of data to every single node in the 1,000-node
cloud environment, which will cost you $6
million, at that time.
And the other was talking about just processing
six one petabyte data in 1,000 processing
elements, which will cost just a couple of
thousand, which is much more manageable.
The reason that I'm really highlighting this,
when you're talking about different infrastructures
and different ways of parallelizing, make
sure that you're talking about parallelizing
the same application.
We are not talking about making the program
much larger than what it was doing initially.
Make sure that you have the best [? sequential
?] [? per ?] program in place, so that you
can actually focus on parallelizing it.
So I will end up with a summary.
I know I showed you too many things.
But I really want you leave this presentation
with keeping in mind these three rules and
what it can give you.
I'm not expecting turn all of you into computer
scientists.
And as last week [? Trey ?] highlighted, don't
try to be Jack of all trades.
It's not good.
The best thing is to find the right collaborator
to work which you for the right set of problems.
This could be specialized biologist or this
could be a computer scientist like myself
or others.
But what I'm hoping that this lecture gave
you-- an overview when you think about your
application, what are the places that you
need to look for making your application faster?
And this will be a starting point discussion
with your computer scientist colleagues.
So again, just quickly, the three things is--
one, we really need to focus what's the most
time-consuming?
What's the common case?
But you also think about, how frequent that
is?
If it's just the 50% of your computation,
even if you improve that infinitely, you'll
only get two times speedup.
So don't expect miracles from [? cloud or
?] parallel computing if you're only improving
50% of your computation.
The second is you really need to pay attention
to locality.
And you need to bring the computation to closer
to your CPU when it's possible in single-site
environments.
But when it's not possible, if the data is
really big and you're talking about distributed
environment, then you really think about moving
computation to [? data.
?]
And the third thing is taking advantage of
parallelism.
So almost everything we do has many levels
of parallelism, including [? passed ?] data
and pipeline parallelism.
You really need to take advantage of those.
Don't forget, again, the fastest processor
doesn't mean that your application run fast.
You need to make sure that you find the most
suitable architecture.
So for example, if you're doing a regular
computations like for the image analysis applications
we have shown, the GPUs are great for them
as long as you process [? through ?] a big
chunk of images.
And when talking about GPUs or any other architectures,
you need to make sure that you have a fair
comparison.
Comparing your performance of whole GPU with
a single-core performance is not a good idea.
What you need to be comparing is if you're
comparing a GPU, you really need to compare
against what's the comparable current CPU
using multi-cores of that CPU.
So in regular applications, I've seen GPUs
can be up to 10 times faster in some applications.
But in real life, really, it's about three
to five times faster.
It's not 100 times faster.
But again, it really depends on your application
characteristics.
So that's actually all I want to cover today.
And that's [? half of ?] [? the answer.
?]
That's wonderful, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you so much for that really comprehensive
overview of high performance and cloud computing
and all the factors that go into the decisions
for how you begin the process of parallelizing
your code and applying it.
We have time for a couple of questions.
The first question that we have is really
sort of a little more practical-- is what
sort of rules of thumb or advice could you
give to people on when exactly to begin the
process of deciding that their code is-- could
run faster or whatnot, and I guess in the
context of, could I just improve the performance
of my code by writing better code or do I
decide that, my code is as good as I'm going
to get it, now I should go and try and improve
its speed by going to high-performance computing
solutions such as parallel-
Thank you very much.
This is a fantastic question.
We see this all the time.
And I tried to allude to this a little bit.
But let me expand on that.
So when to decide it's time to make your code
parallel-- the first thing you really need
to make sure that-- you have the fastest sequential
code.
So your code is most optimal in the sequential
setting before going to parallel.
If you have a very inefficient sequential
code, so you can much easily parallelize that.
It's much easier to parallelize that in many
cases.
You can just [? embarrassingly, ?] or what
I guess-- pleasingly parallelize that by partitioning
the work.
But it is highly possible that there's a better
algorithm, there's a faster way of doing that
in sequential setting.
And that could be still much faster than any
parallel example.
One example from-- I have had multiple examples
of this.
We had a [INAUDIBLE] parallel algorithm to
do one
specific task.
And we couldn't get a good speed up.
But it was a parallel algorithm.
Later, another research team came up and they
said they have a framework which it will allow
our parallel algorithm to scale wonderfully--
so linear speed-up.
This fascinated me, of course.
This is something I want.
But when I look at it carefully, yes, their
framework had a good scaling up.
But their sequential execution time was 1,000
times slower than my sequential time.
So in that case, really wasting resources
is not going to help you.
You need to make sure that you have fastest
code.
But of course, when to stop debugging and
making sure that you have the fastest code--
that's a very difficult question.
So you need to look at, again, maybe 80/20
rule.
You don't want to spend 80% of time to make
your code 20% faster.
So you need to look in easy parts that you
can make it fast.
That's very sound advice.
One other question is what sort of technologies
do you see that are currently emerging or
that are on the horizon that will help with
minimizing latency of data transfer so if
you are moving data around, you're not hidebound
by data transfer rates as Internet 2 or whatever--
Internet 3-- I don't know what's on the horizon.
Are those technologies going to be helpful?
There are some technologies, some network
technologies-- would be really helpful in
the higher end right now.
But I'm afraid we have to deal with latency
in our data life more often than we are doing
right now.
And so most of the time, an end user [INAUDIBLE]
is end up in [? workstation.
?] And whatever your university or company's
network is limited, you will be limited with
that.
So InfiniBand, for example, is getting much
faster network.
But if you look at, again, even the earlier
[? plots ?] I've showed you, the improvements
are usually more in bandwidth than latency.
So latency is improving, but at a much slower
pace.
So you really need to get used to low latency
and think about how you can make your algorithm
program faster by focusing on throughput and
maybe looking at parallelism overlapping so
that you gave the illusion of low latency,
or basically focusing on memory hierarchy
and using it better, again, to give low latency.
So again, these-- the rules I laid out-- is
the best thing to do to achieve better latency.
Fantastic.
Well, I'm sorry, everybody who's been writing
in questions.
We've run out of time this morning.
But I want to-- hope you'll join me in thanking
Umit for giving us a wonderful talk this morning
on modern computing cloud distributed in high
performance-- really, some great ideas and
great heuristics there to use as you're thinking
about parallelizing your code.
Please join us again next week, next Friday,
at 9:00 AM Pacific and noon Eastern for another
one in our series of
Big Data to Knowledge Guide to the Fundamentals
of Data Science.
Thank you, everybody.
Have a great day.
Thank you very much for-- everyone for listening.